how's like going bros my name in fact
you want to know my name what is your
name
that's a better question actually my
name is P oh snap its new damn it's
called needed to find a place to hide I
can't just go back it's too cold I need
to place our goddammit sabes no ha ha ha
all right welcome to lastolite this is
one of those really well made custom
stories I hope at least the guy spent
six month on it so you better be
freaking good I'm big look a chasm it
doesn't really look that cold but let's
go inside and see what happens
I wasn't drinking anything why do you
think that I keep questioning me stop
it's not funny
you're not funny don't laugh you weren't
laughing and well this is awkward
I'm sorry I'll do it keep focus on the
game all right
what is this what it says what is all of
this but it's up and down aw snap I
would not go into a castle that look
like this but someone left a note for me
and I do appreciate that
welcome to safe made in 1970 96 and
renovated 8 as lovely when they do that
I hope you will enjoy our technology to
keep us warm and light 150 people I
didn't thought it place the huge that's
what's a lot of girl say what they see
I'm kidding alright let's go to her life
sorry I keep burping it's disgusting
snap it's new I don't know if I want to
go in here whoo snappy suit huh huh what
the hell
I have to carry on I don't want to carry
on that was a teleporting naked guy Oh
Samson Samson all right fine I'll carry
on but I'm not gonna like it
okay I like oh oh don't look at me like
that holy [ __ ] they look at me why I'm
just sleeping what the hell were you
watching me when I was okay I have oh
you try to hide this from me is that
what you were okay I get it I snore and
I talk when I sleep but that doesn't
mean what is going on it mr. chair Billy
I don't know who they are I don't know
why are we doing it I don't like it I
don't like it either
hey I like it I have mine item all right
I just refill it lovely absolutely
lovely
what are we are having a broken crowbar
oh isn't that delighting there you go
sir there you go play with that our
I just gotta eat it now if you read this
note it should say I'm sorry for you but
now there is no time for explanation you
need to know you need to go wrong I mean
now to take the door downstairs but I
need a key to do that probably problem
enter your necessary nokia donde estan
los keys the rusty lock is the rock I
like I need to find the room key I need
to find the room key
how about you do you have the room key I
mean room key room key not anything
perverted in Swedish are you doing panic
I don't like - I don't like that out
what are you doing stop making me spend
that money and I sorry alright maybe
perhaps in the piano all right we are
back I just had a brain you know you
seem Chuck when he roots flashes pity
why do you have in mind
nice the king and there is no key what
are you doing bidding don't do it start
why's that
yeah haha yeah mrs. yeah I'm sorry I did
oh no mr. Schey can't swim oh no he
can't swim I know what I do all right
let's just what I was a bossy jump but
this is my note say I was dragged I
needed
me alright [ __ ] me I'm at a while
alright what oh thank heavens
what okay one more [ __ ] that's what
I'm talking about
hello sandy buddy yeah dude okay I
should take it nice and easy buddies
nice and nice nice
I am jumping like a boss if I fall down
well maybe I should see mr. Sharon I'll
think about it
alright I'm here what do you want tell
me tell me drawers
tell me wash up oh oh okay I'm good I'm
good I'm super gay I'm alive it's
America Jennifer what are you doing
shiny pate I love you I know you do oh
oh
son why did I why did he always come out
of the closet I don't get it oh my god
alright okay what is this oh yeah
why do i boys your leader what is this
tell us that what is all of this I'm
starting to questioning life and what
Jennifer Jennifer I am disappointed what
are you doing there
alright so I wasn't supposed to go here
I don't know there's alright fine I'll
go down here oh look a deer oh look at
that
should I go I don't know I don't want to
go scary oh look at that [ __ ] is just
pumping like a bot yeah I pumped that
that's like piggy murmuring oh I'm
sitting a bit too far away I think oh
maybe here's a clue no I don't think
maybe all right I just totally wait it's
gonna be a commercial oh you may I
[ __ ] hate the switcher commercials
all right um I just had a flash cousin
oh look how did I not see that before
I'm about that but I had the room key
and I found it like a Bosch I mean I'm
the same okay let's jump here jump here
no problem
no muss probably a much as we say in
Sweden alrighty let's say you buy there
and then one more jump and then a third
a jump and that's why quad jump all
right I should just stop talking are you
still staring at the bed Jesus Christ
you really love beds do you well that's
understandable I mean so damn fine that
all right gentlemen I'll be on my way
now all right I don't see how oh snap
but it's this out of trust yet oh no I
don't like this okay I'm just gonna go
straight cuz it's not going straight all
right all right all right okay
let's no no it's strange luck oh no I'm
out of oil I'm out of oil I might've oil
I mind about it I might a boil I don't
like when ah why can't we be friends why
can't we be friends
oh this says push it away I can't
I got damn it alright just keep going a
ship ouch why can't we be friends
ah they are keep staring at the bed they
are quite fascinated perfectly on their
own Oh mr. Sherr what did he do I'm
sorry it was ok watch me muster
hey Rafe damn what the hell that's not
funny
I'm sorry pity I'm sorry I was just
kidding they just died of natural causes
absolutely natural causes
yeah Hey all right sure all right I'm
just gonna keep lighting [ __ ] hi
Aladdin I then and then then them don't
try to hide from me Lana and then I get
them and so drunk
stop being so drunk I just yes
- Jess look at that ass mm-hmm okay all
right I kinda hope to hit the deficit it
there's gonna be bonus of Kingman each
other you've probably seen already
anyway
packages you enjoyed subscribe over
British and I'll see you tomorrow mark
oh it's up Oh gum rest my name tree bad
welcome back to one see some mod called
deaf awaits and the share waits for you
buddy
it is gonna sit there and rip ketchup
all day huh sad all he gonna do like a
guillotine stingily that's lovely and
Perry had smashed into merging into the
living creatures Oh like a - he likes it
check come on bring it to me okay let's
try to actually get something down set
an arm what are you doing here I'm makes
no sense
why are you correct look at this [ __ ]
look at it why are you doing this to me
why why you not talk to me you want a
high five all right there we go sweet
high five bro all right so bear day that
was my arm you high five
I want to be on camera how's it going
brahs
look at this spin you see that [ __ ] they
don't teach you that in school
no they don't alright I'm sorry but I'm
gonna go today all goddamnit
ah [ __ ]
yo no me gusta no no no señoras and
Sardinia Rita's I I don't like this okay
it's gonna come in a second I know it oh
[ __ ] okay
oh okay bad you are doing this left huh
yeah yeah you're like a mouse gonna come
on gonna get buns gonna come on Bugaboo
Omega able to get a buddy girl a break
over here man aah splashes blue which
led which way which way which way which
made this way I like to be good I think
we lost him
nope bananas up with end up with dad and
up with Ed an oppa didn't know we didn't
know ah I know this was your [ __ ] you
are literally pulling out this [ __ ] ah
thank heavens huh whoo Sammy's newest
app sure he was I dare he was like hey I
know he runs faster for a Waterwalker
nation here I can't even talk what is
going on here hi today what is up and
down I left mr. door
and the game crash isn't that fantastic
I just love it when the game crash go
are you doing I'm sorry for your
disabilities hey don't come closer
don't come closer stop I'm sorry Georgia
Kelly oh sorry speak normally